everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm so they're gonna be going
over game four from 2014 will chess
championships quick recap game one was a
draw we didn't expect too much vision on
had the white pieces but usually again
in a big tournament like that's the the
first game no one's trying to do
anything too much just trying to get
back in the rhythm of playing high level
chess so first game was the draw Magnus
Carlsen came out in the second game with
the white pieces played a very very
great game put a lot of pressure on his
opponents ended up winning that game and
then the last game Game three Vichy and
not actually with the white pieces did
something it didn't do very often and he
beat Magnus Carlsen so we are all
squared away tied up but going into game
number four Magnus Carlsen is going to
be playing the white pieces Vichy and on
is going to be playing the black pieces
so we're go ahead and get with it Magnus
Carlsen again starts with kind of that
very aggressive opening he likes that
pawn here to e4 very different than
mission on usually starting with that
pawn here to d5 or excuse me d4 and
bishan on kind of took everyone by
surprise he played the Sicilian offense
now this is Cillian offense is a very
great defense but it usually leads to a
lot of sharp lines and usually there's a
winner and so this is basically saying
hey Magnus Carlsen just won't let you
know a one last game I'm feeling pretty
good and I'm coming to actually take
points even when I'm playing as black so
that's pretty cool to see we were
expecting more of a long drawn-out
boring draw game and so the Sicilian
defense definitely kind of setting the
tone for a potentially exciting game
Magnus Carlsen decided to attack the
Sicilian offense with the Kings Indian
attack so just kind of going through
here it's more of a system than it is a
series of moves you can kind of get here
even play it against a different
defensive Sicilian French defense those
are some of the main lines did you play
the Kings Indian attack against but it's
it's kind of a slowish style play if
you're pretty familiar with it it's not
the most dynamic there's not a lot of
crazy lines attacking the Sicilian
defense so I was a little surprised by
Magnus Carlsen I'm not sure if he was
caught off guard by the Sicilian offense
but he definitely didn't attack it with
the most aggressive
offense that he could have but we
continue with the normal Kings Indian
attack castling on a king side here
Knight to f6 getting ready to get the
dark squared bishop involved into the
game castle on the Kings side as well
both sides going to be looking to
control this efile right here what's
going to continue just to develop get
his other minor pieces involved into the
game pushing forward here first with
pawn to d4 Bishop to e7 is we talked
about Bishop to e3 development move also
just adding another defender on this
pawn here on d4 we see the exchange in
the knight coming over here to d4 could
have taken a number of different ways
but decided he want to go ahead and open
up the door for his light square bishop
to kind of control this center square
right here so vision on does have the
last central pawn also something to keep
note it is an isolated pawn but
eventually it could become a passed pawn
could also become a very dangerous
passed pawn depending on how magnus
carlsen defends going into the late game
so we see Bishop to g4 again both sides
just continuing that development not
getting out of hand too fast Queens to
d3 next will be just to get the the
knight involved connect the rooks and
then Magnus Carlsen will be done with
his development Queen here to d7 this
opens up the door for potentially
cancelling on the the Queen side but
there's no way that Michigan odds gonna
do that with the semi open C file there
just be too much attacking prowess that
Magnus Carlsen could have so he's gonna
be cancelling on the King side Knight -
d - it's kind of we talked about just
developing castling on the King side for
Vichy and on and the knight to f3 kind
of interesting move you know replacing
the night here on f3 from the knight
that came over here to b1 so you don't
see it too often but Magnus Carlsen is
really starting to put a lot of pressure
on the King side I be interesting to see
if he starts to push on the Queen side
as well I I do think especially in the
Kings in D and the fact that the Kings
Indian attack it's overlooked sometimes
and so this may be an opportunity to try
to attack on the Queen side since
there's not much going on over here but
right now he's content just moving all
of his pieces over to the King side
rook over here to e8 again controlling
that long foul rooks always belong on a
semi-open file or
lately Open File the more room any piece
especially the rook can control it's
definitely going to be better for them
so rook here to e1 kind of countering
attacking that Bishop here to d6 opening
up the door more of a centralized square
but also opening up the door for this
rook to really control here pawn to c3
not only defending this pawn or this
square here on d4 but also consolidating
a little bit of the defense of this
square here on a B for making sure his
opponent can't bring his Bishop down
here to be for his knight down here to
be for so again just solidifying pawn
chain a little bit there's no great
place for him to go so you know they're
just trying to slowly improve each of
their position so pawn here to h6 again
just kind of blocking off solidifying
this is g5 square right here
interesting move from Magnus Carlsen
right here he plays Queen here to f1 now
a lot of the the high level players
natural sport actually short made a
comment that he thought this was a great
move he even put exclamation point but
I'm not sure if he meant that but he
said this was a classic Magnus crossing
move where at when you look at it
doesn't look like it's doing too much
but it it's just really difficult for
your opponent to play against it you
know machine on may have wanted to play
Bishop here to h3 and then maybe an
exchange right here or that's not good
anymore you know for Magnus Carlsen I
think he had a few other options yes
Queen to f1 is difficult to deal with
but it's not very aggressive he's still
just kind of sitting back not doing too
much not being super creative like I've
seen him in the past I think other moves
pawn here to a 5 or a 4 seems a lot more
aggressive starting to attack on the
Queen side you know even Queen here to
c2 is fine he's kind of opened up this
door with pawn here to c3 so this adds
in a defender if he ever wants to play
this pawn here to a4 but it's still
controlling the light squares in the
game again he played this Queen here to
f1 which a lot of people think is good I
don't think it does much form but again
he's Magnus Carlsen he's the best player
in the world so hopefully there was a
very good reason for that Bishop back
here to h5 and the Magnus Carlsen again
he had a few options you could have
continued on the Queen side
he instead played pawn here to h3 so
black has a much more aggressive
approach to this game Magnus Carlsen is
just kind of consolidating all his
pieces in this a little area in front of
his King he's not really trying to push
forward put a lot of pressure on his
opponent you could have played even even
Knight to h4 starting just move his
knight up the board starting to attack
some of the central squares
you know Knight here to f5 eventually
might have been good after h4 he does
have a defender with his knight so a few
different options
he chose the safer route with pawn to h3
UNAM brought his bishop back here to g6
and then rook over here to d1 again you
usually want to after you connect your
rooks to centralize them and control the
open and semi open files so the rook
here is on the open file bring the rook
over here to the semi open file and
that's exactly what you want to do the
works I'm swimming over here to d8 again
kind of countering that now the Knights
going to exchange we do see an exchange
back here on a c6 and then pawn to c4
trying to break up the central square
you know controlling the center
especially in chess is very very
important so Magnus Carlsen wants to get
this essential square from an on off the
board vision on has no desire to go
ahead and exchange right here he wants
to be the one that has the central
square if there is going to be an
exchange he wants to be the one
recapturing so he has that control and
it kind of has that lead in tempo so
he's not gonna do anything right now is
he's gonna play Bishop here to e4
because if there is an exchange you know
this is much better he now recaptures
and so he kind of has that tempo
compared to his opponent recapturing
here so he's gonna play Bishop here to
e4 then Bishop here to d4 the Knights
gonna come back here to h7 so did a few
different ways again this Bishop is
attacking this night vision on doesn't
necessarily want this Bishop to take
here on f6 and recapture here so he
could play Knight here to h7 what she
did the the computer if you guys were
watching the analysis actually
recommended Knight here - or rook here
to e6 kind of an interesting move
you usually don't want to be recapturing
with your rook here on f6 I thought that
was an interesting move that I probably
ones have played but you know I guess
when you are a computer and you think of
3,500 rating or whatever you have some
some crazy way that you like to play but
I think it was a pretty safe player to
go and just play Knight here to h7 again
it wasn't doing a whole lot so
eventually he'll want to get that
involved but right now I doesn't want to
recapture and have doubled pawns here on
the F file and not have either pawns
connected if he had a pawn right here on
f6 and he also had an his EEP on things
would be okay but since he doesn't he
doesn't want to have four pawn chains on
board there's simply going to be bad
going into the endgame so we see the
pawn capture here on d5 and then
recapture here on a d5 with the bishop
so that's kind of how an on wanted to
capture we do see an exchange off the
board all of a sudden some of the pieces
starting to fly off the board which is
nice because again both players haven't
been doing too much Magnus Carlsen
hasn't been pushing the action vichy and
on you know play the Sicilian defense
but he hasn't really tried to get in any
creative or sharp tactical lines either
so good to see they're at least trying
to exchange off some pieces maybe
something happens from there a knight
coming back here to f8 getting ready to
come to e6 more of a central square for
that night Knight over here to h4 Bishop
to e5 centralizing we now see some
exchanging in the middle of the board
and then pawn here to b3 being attacked
by the Queen here on e5 and then we see
the knight coming here to e6 as we
talked about so both sides again just
almost looking like they're trying to
exchange just to get to the in game not
even really trying to win in my opinion
so Knight coming back here to f3 Queen
to f6 attacking so the Kings can come up
here to defend this rook over here to d8
the Queen's just going to move comes
down here to d5 more of a central square
but it's not really attacking too much
there is an exchange off the board so
black does have a passed pawn now on the
D file so we can start to push that that
looks like to be
the only hope that either side has on
board unless there's a huge mistake
which has been prone to happen in these
games between these two players night
here to e5 Queens to f5 Knight coming
back here to d3 Knight to d4 I would
kind of push up pawn to g4 starting to
attack on the Kings side a little bit
forcing the Queen to move back Queen to
e5 so Magnus Carlsen putting a little
bit of pressure there's not not any
great squares you can really go to Queen
to b5 we do see an exchange off the
board - all of a sudden we go into the
king and queen in game which is very
very difficult for one side to win you
know has to make sure that you don't
move your king too much and it's not too
exposed your opponent can then start to
gobble up pieces while he's checking you
kind of change around the board but
especially if you have it near your
Queen it's gonna be very very difficult
for your opponent to do that because you
can always just kind of block so Vichy
and odds gonna be trying to push forward
with this pawn but - crossing you know
with a pretty active Queen is gonna make
sure that that does not happen Queen
here to be for the King comes back here
starts to push a little bit Magnus
Carlsen just starts to check and take
material and then pawn pawn to h4 the
Queen coming over here to a2 Queen to e6
again both sides there's just not a lot
for them to do all of a sudden we see
them repeat some moves and because of
that they decided to go ahead and draw
so it was a long game it was over it was
around 4 hours so if you kind of watched
it you kind of saw this it wasn't very
exciting afterwards they asked Magnus
Carlsen he said he's just not playing
very well he really didn't like how this
game went last game obviously he said he
didn't play very well he lost that game
so hopefully Magnus Carlsen can can get
it inspired I've seen him play a lot
better and he excel acknowledged that
he's just not playing very well he's not
seeing the lines that he's used to
seeing in these games so we have a day
off tomorrow rest for these players then
we come back for two more exciting games
so
hoping the vision on when he comes back
with the white pieces feels like he kind
of has the edge right now even though
we're tied I feel like he's playing the
better chess so we'll see if he can
start to take the lead in his next match
in a couple days so thank you guys for
watching hopefully you enjoyed and I'll
see you guys in the next one